there are new questions this morning
about how the Minneapolis police officer
who killed the beloved yoga teacher was
trained investigators say that Justine
Damon was shot by Officer Mohamed nor
after she called 911 a possible sexual
assault Jamie yuccas has had Minneapolis
police headquarters where this
investigation has caused a big change in
leadership Jamie good morning good
morning the Minneapolis mayor said that
she was frustrated by the lack of
leadership with police Janee harteau and
that's why she asked for her resignation
but critics are also very frustrated
that there isn't more information about
justine Damon's death at the same time
officer Noir is still refusing to speak
to investigators Minneapolis mayor Betsy
Hodges has faced angry calls to step
aside on Friday she said it was time for
new leadership at the police department
accepting the resignation of chief Janee
harteau she replaced her with midoriya
Arredondo a 28-year veteran of the force
there is no magic wand for Public Safety
this weekend a new witness came forward
a bicyclist who stopped at the scene of
the deadly shooting investigators are
still trying to figure out why Officer
Mohammad noir opened fire from the
passenger seat of his police vehicle
across his partner's body striking
justine Damon through the open driver's
side window now a week after Damon's
death questions are being raised about
Officer NORs training in 2015 Noor
joined the Minneapolis Police through a
program for college graduates without a
degree in criminal justice or law
enforcement he graduated college with a
business degree their alternative
licensing programs essentially criminal
justice scholar James Bentley says NORs
education and training only pains part
of the picture we also need to look at a
little bit deeper in terms of officer no
sort of background his attributes his
behavior what his colleagues fully
confident in his abilities as a police
officer during that time the Minneapolis
Police denied it fast track's any
candidates saying the program nor
graduated from has helped the MPD hire a
number of highly qualified and decorated
officer
including many of our current Chiefs
inspectors and commanders Damon had
called 911
of her fiance Don he told the New York
Times quote I have played this over in
my head over and over why didn't I stay
on the phone with her and just yesterday
Don Damon went to the bridal shop to see
Justine's wedding dress for the first
time they were to be married next month
Gale just heartbreaking all the way
around thank you very much Jamie